a group of cops tried to break up a holy
week
service in canada a few days ago the
pastor of that church
did not take very kindly to their visit
go out and don't come back i don't want
to talk to you
[Music]
immediately out i don't care what you
have to say
out out out of this property or nazis
out
is not allowed here immediately gestapo
is not
allowed out
do you understand english get out of
this property
go so go go and don't come back without
the warrant
out nazi out out
you understand nazis are not welcome
here out
and don't come back without a warrant do
not come back without a warrant you
understand that
you're not welcome here nazis are not
welcome here
gestapo is not welcomed here do not come
back you
nazi psychopaths
unbelievable sick evil people
intimidating people in a church during
the passover
love him i want to make him an honorary
american what has gone wrong in our
country
that americans need to take lessons on
freedom
and religion from canadians i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday
olivia v who says kids being thrown over
a wall
and no calls for joe biden's impeachment
wow that d
next to a politician's name is like a
force field that protects them from the
consequences of their actions
it's exactly like a force field it's a
force field in the sense that
when a politician on the left does
something that would have gotten a
politician on the right in trouble
the force field of not just the media
but big technology and corporate america
and
the activist foundations and the
universities
and everything and the whole edifice of
establishment liberalism
rushes to the left winger's defense
whereas on the right that entire edifice
turns against them so it actually it is
a force field
and conservatives need to build a force
field of our own by the way
you're not going to be able to do any of
that kind of great political work if you
haven't gotten a good night's sleep so
that's why i would highly recommend you
check out my pillow
my pillow the reason that i sleep so
easy i've got a screaming baby
i've got my wife taking up three
quarters of the bed doesn't matter
a lot of people really like my pillow
because they like the political
affiliation of the company you know it's
a little more of a conservative company
i'm going to make an admission to you
right now i
i think i would buy my pillow even if it
were a communist country i know i don't
want to sound like a disloyal american
but it's
that's how good the pillow is they are
it's the best pillow i've ever
used and now my wife sweet little elisa
is walking around
in my slippers they have these slippers
they offered me a pair of slippers i
being a good husband who didn't want my
wife to divorce me i said would you like
the celebrity she did she loves them the
slippers took over two years to develop
they are designed to wear indoors slash
outdoors whatever you want all day long
the my slippers are made with my pillow
foam and impact gel to help prevent
fatigue
and they're made with quality leather
suede i can tell you these are
unbelievable i kind of got to
try them just a little bit you know and
then at least i took them right back
right now my pillow is offering 40
off their new my slippers 40 off so i
got the sheets i got the pillows i got
the slippers from my pillow
like all of their products comfort is
the key go check them out they're
amazing go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square use
promo code daily wire you'll get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper the my pillow
towel sets
or you can call 800-951-7163 use promo
code daily wire go to mypillow.com now
or call 800-951-7163
happy easter everybody vain the stone
the watch the seal christ has burst the
gates of hell
death in vain forbids his rise christ
hath opened
paradise this was i think that's a isn't
that a
presbyterian line i don't know i i heard
this
verse during an excellent catholic
homily on easter sunday
and i won't say which church this was at
or who the
priest was because i don't i don't want
him to be
sent into the gulags or something for
for for
making a conservative statement but it
was a really important
homily because the priest pointed out
that on easter sunday
throughout our entire civilization we
once understood
that death has been robbed of its
threats of its power christ conquers
death
and so we don't live our lives like
little
wimps fearing death all the time
but now because we are living in a
culture where christianity is rapidly
declining in public
we are all terrified we have a neurotic
paranoid fear of death we are now living
in a fear of death cult
we are every little thing the last year
and a half
has shown this most clearly there were
warning signs before that
we don't have thanksgiving anymore
public health officials tell us not to
have thanksgiving we don't see our
family
we don't see our friends i'm not talking
about you and me i suspect if you're
listening to this show right now
you've probably been ignoring the
exalted dr fauci for
approximately oh the entire time
but for a bunch of other people in this
country they have followed
these rules they don't see people they
don't live their lives they won't go to
work they wear the stupid mask on their
face
they muzzle themselves up like good good
little boys and girls like good little
sheep
and they they tremble at the very
thought that they might die
there are two things to know here one is
the statistical statistical likelihood
that you will die that you will suffer a
physical death
is just about 100
very very unlikely you're unless i guess
unless
we live through the second coming of
christ which entirely possible but
that'll be that'll present its own set
of challenges i think for a lot of
people
otherwise you're gonna die okay and the
message of easter is
there's a way out there's a there's a
way after the physical death
there is a way to have eternal life so
you don't need to worry about it you
don't need to live in fear of the tyrant
this is why christianity is considered
the greatest political revolution in the
world is that
tyrannical rulers the only thing they
have on you is the fear that they can
instill in you that they'll kill you and
christianity says all right whatever do
whatever you want feed me to a lion i
don't really care
but now we're living in this neurotic
fear and it's making us all
nuts and it's and it's ruining the life
that we have
do not fall into that guys i'm not
saying
i don't i'm not praying that we hasten
my death or anything like that i'm not
not saying that i'm uh necessarily you
know
driving corvettes you know really
quickly on the side of mountains i can
take a prudential care of my life
but i'm not that afraid of death i'm
afraid of suffering i would be kind of
sad i you know i wouldn't want to leave
my family in a bad spot
but we don't need to live in this crazy
fear of death
and until we acknowledge that
the fouchies of the world are going to
continue
to to guide us around like we're a bunch
of terrified little sheep
because we're not living in a christian
polity really anymore there's still a
lot of christians here and
but i think for the first time ever
church attendance is less than 50
in the united states we talked about
that that public opinion survey last
week
so this thing is is declining pretty
rapidly
and in its place it makes the matters
even worse you have some people who call
themselves christian who manifestly or
not
one person is raphael warnock he's the
the senator from georgia now i will
we'll get into georgia voting laws more
this week but he
he won because you know because georgia
voting is so evil and terrible
joe biden was said to have won the state
of georgia and uh raphael warnock got it
and john ossoff got it they're saying
you know it seems a little strange guys
i don't know all this
widespread mail-in voting and all the
election integrity measures were taken
away
we'll get into that controversy in a bit
i want to focus on warnock himself he
refers to himself as reverend
rafael warnock he says that he is a
christian but he is not a christian and
i'm not saying this like he's a sinner
he's a bad guy i'm not wagging my finger
at him i'm just
staying as a very basic matter of what
he believes he is not a christian
he tweeted out on easter quote the
meaning of easter is more transcendent
than the resurrection of jesus christ
whether you are christian or not through
a commitment to helping others we are
able to save ourselves
the meaning of easter is not more
transcendent than the resurrection of
jesus christ
i don't think there is anything more
transcendent than that but certainly
that is what easter is about and if you
are christian
or whether or if you're not christian a
commitment to helping others
will not let you save yourself this is
called the heresy of pelagius
this is an ancient heresy that the
church got rid of many moons ago
but progressive politicians have tried
to bring back
you cannot reasonably call yourself a
christian if you believe that you can
save yourself
absent the crucifixion and resurrection
of jesus christ
a lot of libs are trying to blur the
lines on this and it gets to a political
strategy that they they employ but look
what raphael warnock is doing has a long
history in progressive politics
but it's not christianity but a lot of
people have done this before
okay martin luther king people probably
like martin luther king a lot more than
they like raphael warnock
martin luther king also denied the
essentials of christianity he also
denied
the virgin birth he denied the divinity
of christ and he denied the resurrection
i'm not saying that you can't do some
good things if you
if you are not a christian or if you
deny christianity
i'm not saying you can't be an
influential person
you just can't be a christian if you
deny those things
what whitaker chambers called the the
great alternative faith of mankind
that was communism whitaker chambers was
an ex-communist
his book witness helped make ronald
reagan into a conservative
i've actually seen reagan's copy of
witness at the reagan ranch still on his
bookshelf
but he referred to communism as as the
alternative faith he goes back to the
garden of eden when the serpent told eve
ye shall be his gods
i don't know that raphael warnock is a
chris is a communist rather
he sort of intimates that he might be he
he was very excited and exuberant to
welcome fidel castro to his
church years ago he has said things that
would would tend to
paint him as a pinko but whether he
thinks he's a communist or not whether
we want to apply this term to
progressivism
more broadly this is an alternative
faith and it's a faith that's winning
over a lot of
squishies in christianity and
in the country in our politics more
broadly the left is much subtler than
the right they do this
very well they infiltrate and they
invert you might have seen a group
called catholics for choice
which is being led by a man who thinks
that he's a woman
this is not possible this is a
contradiction in terms there are many
many problems with this group
but it the not the least of which is it
is simply not possible to be a catholic
who supports legal abortion you can't do
i suppose you can be a baptized catholic
but you cannot be in a state of grace
you cannot receive the sacraments if you
were doing this sort of thing you're in
a state of grave mortal sin
you are contradicting the faith on very
grave matters
and you can't call yourself really
a catholic if you do that we can we need
to start
using this strategy in a in a moral way
on the right we're not very subtle on
the right
maybe i don't know maybe we're sort of
some of the great offenders of this
those of us in the media
where we just bluntly we say look this
is what we think this is what we're
doing this is what's wrong
and i think we need that i think we need
to maintain clarity as well but there is
also a role for institutional cleverness
you know we need to be innocent as doves
and wise as serpents
we need to infiltrate established
institutions just like the radicals did
and we need to use that to attain
cultural hegemony to use antonio
gramsci's phrase i describe a lot of
this in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
just like the radicals did we need to
insist on teaching
the bible in schools and and say it's
part of multiculturalism
let's say it's part of social justice
there's a long-standing catholic social
justice tradition
we need to make curriculum more
eurocentric again we need to start
teaching
our own history again and we can justify
it in the name of avoiding cultural
appropriation i don't know
we can use the left's
established institutions and we can use
the left's lexicon
in a subtle way i'm not saying we evade
what we believe i'm not saying
that we play it down or anything like
that
i don't think we should lie certainly
not but we can be
clever we can do both of these things
just
like the left does because the left
plays to win
and the left wins and if you want to win
great discounts on your auto parts i
would strongly recommend
rock auto rockauto.com is a family
business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years they have the doodads they have
the gizmos they have the
whatchamacallits you know i'm not
exactly
the most expert when it comes to car
parts that is why it's so humiliating
when i go into the brick and mortar car
parts store because you go in they ask
you a million questions you don't know
the answer to
they go on the back they never have the
part they order it online probably from
rockauto.com then they charge you
twice as much don't do that why would
you subject yourself to that
rockauto.com they they don't have
gimmicks on their pricing
it's not like oh on tuesday it's this
percent off but then you've got to wait
until wednesday and it's this no it's
reliably low prices
the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
the catalog is so simple and intuitive
and easy to navigate
even i can do it which is quite
impressive
a great selection all the parts that
your car is ever going to need go to
rockauto.com right now
see all those parts for your car or
truck then write knowles canon wles
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know we sent you
of course if conservatives
mimic the tactics of the left and do so
in a
moral way but still use the same kinds
of techniques
the left will wail and gnash their teeth
i'll give you a great example of this
there was a washington post article
inside a stealth persuasion machine
promising republican victories in 2022
describes all these awful persuasion
persuasion machine
getting engagement all this sort of
stuff this was tweeted out by
some blue checklist named justin
hendrick says in florida
illinois michigan ohio and virginia a
shady non-profit
backed by republicans is behind a
stealth
effort to build facebook pages to reach
millions of voters it plans to expand
to a-z-i-a-m-n-p-a-t-x and w-i
all those states reports isaac
stanbecker who wrote
this piece in the washington post
so just to get this straight and i'm not
going to go too much into the georgia
issue here
we'll we'll get to that later on in the
week
when republicans try to tighten up
election integrity the left
wails and says this is voter suppression
when republicans try to expand the
number of people who vote
the left wails and gnashes its teeth and
says this is
shady this is a
machine this is i don't know they
they've got to work on their language
here when we try to reduce the number of
voters
to only the eligible ones bad when we
try to expand the number of voters among
the eligible ones
bad do you get it yet do you understand
what's going on
anything republicans do to try to to win
an election
is going to be called illegitimate and
awful i mean
what's going on in georgia is so crazy
they're trying to say as always the left
does they're trying to say this is
racist white supremacist
race race race has absolutely nothing to
do with race it's
it's the most basic commonsensical
aspect of our republic that if our
because our republic is based on the
consent of the governed
and constitutionalism if we
can't have trust in our elections
if we can't have faith that only the
people who are supposed to vote are
voting
that the result we're seeing at the
ballot box is legit if we can't have
faith in that we can't have faith in
any other part of our government
the left is saying this is terrible and
racist and we can't have it
so who cares what they say just do it
just do it just go in and wield some
political power
great example of this senator cruz and
senator
lee down involving
georgia so major league baseball the
only sport i've ever liked
is alienating me as a fan
because major league baseball is
canceling the all-star game
in in georgia they're going to move that
all-star star game somewhere else why
because of georgia's awful terrible
jim crow racist voter law
that is still more lenient than most
at least many states in the country
including very left-wing states like new
york
new york has significantly more
restrictive voter laws
than georgia does now under the
republican bill
so is mlb are they going to move the
game to
to new york will they that would be
weird wouldn't it that'd be awkward
they wouldn't even have to justify it
they wouldn't they would just do it
right because georgia
currently has a republican governor new
york has a democrat governor
democrats according to the their own
logic the
the democrat state is worse but it just
doesn't matter i mean don't forget
they hailed andrew cuomo as the great
covid savior
he was the great hero of coronavirus he
was the worst
governor in the country by a long shot
on coronavirus committed crimes
in his handling of coronavirus doesn't
matter they won't answer for that
when they try to hold him accountable
because he's not looking good on tv
they'll just get him on some other thing
they'll say he winked at his secretary
so
probably it's not going to be a big deal
which is why republicans need to
exercise political power here cruz and
lee
are calling on the federal government
uh jeff duncan too who's a
representative and you know he's a
republican in the house of
representatives
they want to strip the mlb of anti-trust
exemptions
that grant them immunity from federal
anti-monopoly laws
mike lee pointed out that mlb has
legal protections that other sports
leagues like the nfl and the nba don't
have
so they should lose those
well but michael that's you're only
doing this because the mlb went woke
yup that's true you you got it
well but michael that the left wields
government power
and we don't want to be like the left
uh don't we don't want to win we don't
want to be successful we don't want to
have a sophisticated understanding of
politics
i don't want to wield government power
in the same way that the left is doing
it
because i think the stuff that the left
is doing
is bad the stuff that government that
the left is wielding government power
for is bad but so i don't want to do
that i want to wield government power
for good stuff
like all politics comes down to like
republicans
have done until very very recently
like we all understood is the end of
government like the people gave us power
to do
goodness gracious i am so glad this is
sort of tangential to the point on the
mlb anti-trust protections i am so glad
that i cancelled my mlb tv membership it
actually hurt me because it's the only
sport i like so i'd watch the yankees
and i cancelled it last year when mlb
said they were going to
reverse the letters and put blm on the
pitchers map i said i'm out i'm done
i don't care i i paid for the year i
think or but there were some issues with
it and i think
i was able to save so i just i didn't
even care if i paid already paid for it
i was going i just
wrote to them i said cancel my
membership they canceled it i really
wanted to start it up again this year
but they keep up the nonsense they don't
get my money and that's that
they don't want my money they don't need
my money or they they don't want
a relationship with conservatives that's
fine
they don't there are limits here folks
i'm all for a very broad realm where
private companies can do what they want
and pursue their interest i think that's
great and i like free markets and all
that stuff
when a woke corporation like the mlb
tries to undermine election integrity in
my republic
that's too far then i've got to start
exercising my political power
and if you are still laboring under this
ridiculous
shallow libertarian notion that cropped
up over the last 10 years that
private companies should be able to do
absolutely whatever they want including
betraying and undermining our polity i
can't help you okay if you still believe
well build your own twitter build your
own youtube
oh yeah mlb wants to undermine our
election system
that's fine it's a private company no
sorry buddy
that ain't conservative that ain't
conserving
nothing rand paul also called out
the mlb because he he gets this you know
there's two sides here we always hear
well we conservatives need to act in the
culture
and we focus too much on politics we
need to work in the culture actually we
don't focus on either and we need to
focus on both
we need yes we need to take personal
actions here cancel your mlb membership
don't go to the stupid hollywood movie
you don't want to support we also need
to take political actions
you do both at the same time and rand
paul tweeted out quote
your sports league might be a little too
woke if it will
freely do business with communists in
china and cuba
but boycott's a u.s state that wants
people to show an id to vote hashtag mlb
all-star game hashtag
mlb of course of course this is true
i mean you need to show an id to buy a
beer at yankee stadium
i know this because i was turned away
many times when i was 18
19 20 years old but you're not
supposed to show an id to vote i i am
beginning to think
that this is less about left versus
right
and more about i don't know call it
nationalism versus globalism
it's less about republicans versus
democrats and more about
america versus the liberal global regime
because yeah they're not going to call
out china joe biden's not going to do
anything here joe biden
pressured the mlb to leave georgia but
he's not going to pressure
any company not to support the olympics
this
this chinese showcase joe biden isn't is
barely going to say a harsh word about
china
because china is part of this
international
regime whereby we well they buy a lot of
our debt we got us
we got to buy their products they they
invest a lot and look it's fine it's
cool
we don't want to we can we can afford to
lose those troglodyte conservatives
but we can't afford to lose china so the
nba is not going to say anything about
china it's very big there
we're just not going to upset anything
just as long as we have global trade
that's all fine and we're all
it's all good and we support the u.n and
the who
and the imf and wto that's really
the political battle here between
competing political institutions
and competing political loyalties
you will hear much more about this on
ben's show today ben is back you know i
was filling in on his radio show last
week he's going to be back
today uh but ben ben is a huge baseball
fan so he's going to be talking a lot
about what's going on there also as we
return from
easter and passover it's very important
to reflect on
what these holidays mean for us and for
our culture more and more the left wants
to erase
the values and replace them with their
own religion i mean this is what we're
talking about today
the religion of progressivism and this
is something that is going to be a big
focus of candace owens on her new show
the show streams on fridays at 9 pm
eastern 8 p.m central at dailywire.com
you can get the audio podcast canvas on
apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts so if you need
some candace owens in your podcast feed
look no further
head on over to apple podcasts or
spotify to subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you hear we'll be right
back with a lot more
joe biden does not support the mlb
playing a baseball game in georgia
because of georgia's
awful terrible vile decision to protect
the ballot box
meanwhile joe biden does support
the olympics and china
which is committing a genocide against
its population it's been committing
genocides against its population for
thousands and thousands of years now but
they've they've
[Music]
taken on a new a new challenge in
killing the uyghur population they
finally let up a little bit on the
one child policy but they committed a
horrific genocide there as well in
recent decades
spurred in no small part by the way by
the environmentalist movement i talk
about that in my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
uh you know it's a vile vile regime that
does
all sorts of awful things joe biden
doesn't have a
terrible thing to say about them so
philip wegman who is a
young reporter he's been on this show
actually in the early days of the show
he was on this show
he asked totally fair question to jen
saki she
really really did not like that question
the president
had voiced his support for mlb making a
decision about the all-star game
in georgia i'm wondering when can we
expect a final determination from the
president about the united states
participating in the beijing olympics
given that he said
the chinese president doesn't have a
democratic bone in his body
well i think the us olympic committee uh
would play a big role in uh
in on major league baseball here in the
united states he actually
didn't i i think i don't know if you
heard the q the answer the question the
answer that happened a few minutes ago
where we addressed this and
i answered the question so and i give a
little more context but maybe you
weren't paying attention to that part
yeah spoiler alert she did not answer
the question but of course she didn't
because if she had answered the question
she would repeat her answer right here
it's a v a very simple question why is
biden
being tougher on americans wanting to
protect their election in georgia than
he is
on the chinese communists who are
committing genocides
she says well uh well um you know the
the olympic committee will
they'll deal with that and uh yeah oh
gosh that one doesn't jen
jen that wasn't a good one you know
that's not a good answer oh i know what
i'll do i'll just be really smug and
condescending uh maybe you didn't hear
my other answer
maybe you weren't paying attention the
smug thing does not work by the way
i do she this is what she leans on and
it doesn't work
there are there are different tax that a
press secretary could take here
different tax
politicians generally could take with
the media you can
either be extremely prepared and
measured
like kaylee mcinanny right she would
just kill you with a smile she was just
man she was good but she wasn't wasn't
condescending in any way
you can be a total just bulldog like
sarah sanders she would just pummel just
viciously
beat the media just every day she'd go
into that press room
uh trump obviously takes takes in that
strategy as well
or you can do this condescending thing
that i i really don't think that plays
well
for anybody and she's not going to
answer the question and no one really
expects that she would
fortunately there are still a handful of
voices in sports
that have not completely lost it that
actually see
what's going on here and see it better
than a lot of con conservatives in
politics
charles barkley charles barkley was on
cbs
talking about sports i don't really
remember exactly what he was talking
about
and because now when all of our sports
conversations somehow come back to
politics
charles barkley said you know this is a
this is a game
this is a political tactic to divide
americans
man i think most white people and black
people are great people
i really believe that in my heart but i
think our system is set up
for our politicians whether they're
republicans or democrats
are designed to make us not like each
other so they can keep
their grasp of money and power they
divide and conquer
i truly believe in my heart most white
people and black people are awesome
people
but we're so stupid following our
politicians whether they're republicans
or democrats
and their only job is hey let's make
these people not like each other
we don't live in their neighborhoods
we're all got money
let's make the whites and blacks not
like like each other
let's make rich people and poor people
not like each other
uh let's let's scramble the middle class
i
truly believe that in my heart this is
obviously true this is a classic tactic
by the way
of uh corporations against unions i
think there were some leaked memos from
amazon about this
how the trick to preventing unionization
is to get all the workers to hate each
other because if the workers have
solidarity they'll unionize and then
you'll have to negotiate with them
so corporations have been employing this
for a long time and continue to employ
this today
marx tried to do this on the basis of
class he believed that
when the workers of the world united and
got together there would be a workers
revolution and it would overthrow
this sort of bourgeois capitalist
industrial system that didn't happen and
uh so marx in that way died of failure
but but his
ideological errors the western marxists
cultural marxist neo-marxists whatever
term you want to use
they they recognized the the problem
that
that uh marx had i talk about this at
great length by the way in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds because it ties directly into
political correctness wokism cancel
culture again whatever term you want to
use
what guys like antonio gramsci realized
this communist italian politician and
and marxist theorist was that the
conservatives had a cultural hegemony so
the workers just didn't they just didn't
feel that oppressed right they didn't
they didn't know
that they were oppressed they were
laboring under what he would call a
false consciousness
so what you had to do was indoctrinate
them
obviously take over the cultural
institutions but also
you know gin up certain other
antagonisms
this was later brought to fruition under
the frankfurt school the creation of
critical theory we now see
a derivation of that critical race
theory taking over classrooms and
corporate america
uh we saw in the 1960s and 70s a lot of
left-wing foundations recognizing that
if you could
gin up racial identity create whole new
identity groups
hispanics for instance it's a relatively
recent identity group
until very recently you had people from
central and south america they would say
i'm mexican i'm
whatever guatemalan i'm brazilian now
there's this idea that you're
you're hispanic or asian that's a new
identity group
they're trying to create a new one in
the middle east called mina
middle east north africa that one hasn't
really caught on yet it's like fetch and
mean girls you know the people
people just haven't made that one happen
but there was an explicit plan
to divide americans on the basis of race
because
there isn't really a class system in
america so race is the is the fault line
and if you can do that
then the people who are retaining power
can really manipulate people and
really maintain a hold on their power
that's what charles barkley's saying
he's absolutely right and you're seeing
this by the way tyson
with what we were talking about earlier
in the show about the
fear of death cult the left has taken
this to
its perfect conclusion in the
coronavirus revolution of the last year
and a half
whereby we're not even just divided on
race or sex
or class or anything like that we are
now
perfectly divided from everybody we now
it's not just that white people view
black people as a threat to them
or black people view white people as a
threat to them we now
have been instructed to view every
single person that we come into contact
with
not as a dignified human being
possessing an immortal soul
whom we should love as we love ourselves
but as bags of germs
that are out there waiting to kill us
and if they so much as breathe
from behind that filthy cloth covering
that a bunch of
sheep have been persuaded to wear by dr
fauci if they so much as breathe
that is as though they were taking out a
gun and shooting us
that's how dangerous they are because of
coronavirus
it is a perfectly divisive strategy
and some people still go along with it
very bad idea
we we need to encourage you know the
thing i always liked about sports is
that people seem kind of grounded
they seem kind of normal it wasn't
highly ideological
we need to encourage the the remaining
common sense voices there
to speak up draymond green
drake is a basketball player apparently
i don't know who he is i don't watch
basketball
but draymond green made this great point
the other day he was talking about megan
repino
that crazy-haired lady from the soccer
team
who always whines that she doesn't make
enough money she's a millionaire she's
rich she's famous but she
no wow wow i don't make enough money for
playing a sport that not a lot of people
watch
and draymond green said you know lady
you got to quit your whining
it's very it's very unbecoming i'm
really tired of seeing them complain
about the lack of pay because
because they're doing themselves a
disservice
by just complaining you know and
they're not just complaining huh they're
not just complaining
but they are because they're not laying
out steps
that they can take to change that and so
it's coming off as a complaint because
the people that can change it
they're just going to continue to say
what a revenue isn't there
the revenue isn't there so if you don't
bring in the revenue
we can't up your pay they're going to
keep using that but the reality is
as true as that is it's an excuse
because
everyone says we support women we
support women empowerment
we support women in the workplace we do
this for women we do ex for women
blah blah blah and everyone uses it
to their advantage yet these women are
not
using these people that are saying those
very things
to their advantage so then it just
becomes a complaint that falls on deaf
ears
of course of course this is absolutely
right because the
everyone is going to point out it's just
obvious that women sports
don't bring in the revenue that
mensports bring in because men and women
are different and men are
just not as physically strong and
fast and buff as dudes and that's just a
fact of life so when you want to watch
people
racing for instance you want to watch
the fastest people racing well that's
men
when you want to watch people fighting
you want to watch the strongest people
fighting that's
men when you want to watch people
playing team sports goes
on and on so just quit whining lady
that's very unbecoming broadly speaking
pride is ugly vanity is ugly humility is
beautiful
we once knew this but we don't know this
now now
we've we've convinced ourselves as a
culture
that pursuing our own will outside and
in contravention of the moral order
is good somehow because we're breaking
the oppression of the more basically
we're breaking the oppression of the
moral order and liberating ourselves
from reality
liberating yourself not just from the
bond the unjust bonds that have
been put on you but but even from
reality itself you see the the total
expression of this in transgenderism
which is i will liberate myself from
nature
entirely from my own most basic nature
not a recipe for success
you know charles barkley though he makes
this point i mean we're all seeing this
that this is a big business
this big business here the grievance
industry as
draymond green might call it is is big
business
there's a report out from the college
fix do you know how much
money each year university of california
berkeley spends
on diversity equity and inclusion
programs
you know the deans of diversity equity
inclusion the assistant
deans of diversity equity inclusion the
assistant deputy deputy assistant deputy
deans of
diversity equity and inclusion
25 million dollars
25 would be too much money to spend on
these
ridiculous radical subversive programs
25 million 11 percent of that comes from
philanthropy and private grants
okay if they want to spend their money
on stupid nonsense whatever it doesn't
really bug me that much
31 comes from federal and state public
service grants
don't love that don't love that my tax
dollars are going to that
oh and then 58
comes from taxpayers
and tuition and tuition is not very
great at those schools
especially for in-state students she got
a lot coming from the man i'm so glad i
left california
25 million bucks that's a racket
sure it's a way to protect people's
sinacures it's a way to
amass political power where there's big
money there's going to be big influence
that's just the way it goes
that's why they secure a lot of money
for these sorts of programs
it is a way to transform the culture
and create and to push a false narrative
by the way false narrative on race
you can see that narrative in action did
you hear well i guess we were off the
air
uh right right around when this happened
a a young man rammed
his car into two u.s capitol police
officers
before getting out of his vehicle with a
knife
police shot and killed this man
immediately
the usual suspects on the left were
saying this is another insurrection
this is right-wing terrorism this is the
trump issue we've got to have a national
conversation and then it turned out
he's a young black guy who's a follower
of louis farrakhan's nation of islam and
then the story went away
that was it story just went away
actually all ilhan omar could say was
that
this this killing would have been worse
if he had an ar-15
we actually have some evidence that the
ar-15 wouldn't have
as a national issue wouldn't have been a
big deal we'll get into that in just a
second
this narrative it goes it's not even
just in what people say and what people
are taught
it's in the stories that are chosen to
be emphasized it's the
conversation that goes on it's the 25
million dollar department at just one
school of diversity equity and inclusion
it's this institutional power it gets
back to that comment that my favorite
comment from
last week that was brought up at the top
of the show it seems like a force field
around democrats
it is it is it's a very well-funded very
effective force field
and we are all the marks okay we are all
the people who are
who are being influenced by it socially
engineered by it
speaking of murderers beyond what what
went on at the capitol with that
nation of islam follower
you remember those two girls who killed
muhammad anwar
uh he the the pakistani ubereats driver
they jacked his car they brought a taser
gun he wouldn't just give the car to
them so they drove away with him still
clinging to it they killed him
they then walked away they got out of
the car that they flipped but then they
walked right past his dead body because
one of the girls forgot her cell phone
in the car
no care whatsoever so at the very least
these girls should be put away for life
at the very very least under dc law
they might just basically get away with
it so under dc law the 13 year old girl
cannot be prosecuted as an adult
okay i sort of understand that i guess
however it is possible for the 15 year
old girl
to be transferred to an adult court
however very likely won't happen
according to a news report
after the trial if youths are found
responsible meaning guilty
they can be held in juvenile detention
only until age 21
even if they commit a murder and if they
are deemed rehabilitated they can be
freed much sooner than that
because while the adult penal system at
least pretends to
to have something to do with retribution
to have something to do with
punishment the juvenile detention system
is 100
about rehabilitation
a criminal defense attorney nikki lotzey
just said that they could get a plea
agreement
whereby they accept responsibility and
then get home detention
or probation
does that seem just to you
does that seem like oh that's good
because what we're told and you you
increasingly see this in the
academic literature around juvenile
justice is that
basically only a barbarian would ever
want to punish anybody
first of all that
juvenile is a term that needs to be
redefined because people's brains don't
start
stop maturing until they're 25 so we
shouldn't if a 23 year old
murders a bunch of people we shouldn't
necessarily try them as an adult they
might not have known what they were
doing they're not in possession of their
will
how are they supposed to stop it this
full emphasis on rehabilitation
as compassionate and good and on the
actual purpose of
justice right punishment as barbaric or
backward or something like that
if these two girls get off basically
scot-free do you think that's
just do you think do you feel like
justice will have been done
no of course not justice won't have been
done
certainly not to the family of the
victim but the justice won't have been
done to them either they won't have been
rehabilitated
there's a chance if the 13 year old girl
is just
kept in jail for life and if the
older girl is tried as an adult and
either kept in jail for life or executed
with capital punishment there is a
chance they might be rehabilitated
hanging concentrates the mind severe
punishment
concentrates the mind it's an act of
mercy it's an act of compassion
but if they just get off scot-free
no justice will have been done anywhere
for anybody
and i would bet a good chunk of change
that these girls will commit awful
crimes again
speaking of crime and punishment the fbi
while they're letting murderers off the
hook
so so long as it you know goes along
with a broader narrative
they might be coming after you so
there's this issue of vaccine passports
that the left has been pushing
vaccine passports are the idea that
maybe it's the state that imposes it but
maybe it's private businesses
but you won't be able to do anything you
won't be able to engage in commerce
unless you
get the jab of this vaccine that was
produced very rapidly
and then you'll by the way it'll have
your medical history on there so you'll
maybe if there are variants you're going
to need to get more jabs you're going to
need to get boosters and
that's how you're going to prove that
you can engage in society
so a lot of people are thinking no i
don't think i'm going to do that i have
no intention of getting this vaccine
maybe i will
at some point but i i have no intention
of doing it and i have
even less of an intention of using a
vaccine passport
so it raises a moral question if they
require these things
and you feel that it's unjust to require
them
would you forge the passport can't won't
be that hard to forge i don't think
well the fbi is saying now the fbi in
minnesota tweeted out we've all seen
friends posting their coven 19
vaccination cards on social media
if you make or buy a fake one to
misrepresent your vaccination status you
endanger other people and may also be
breaking the law
there's the threat we're gonna we're
gonna throw you in jail
if you murder someone that's fine as
long as it goes along with our narrative
but if you have the wu flu
or don't have the wu flu but you don't
get the jab then we're gonna
spray in prison if you if you forget
that is part of the fear of death cult
the idea that we cannot engage
in any sort of association with anybody
who doesn't who in any way questions the
public health
exalted priests of the religion of
progressivism that is the fear of death
cult
i do want to get back to ilhan omar's
point really quick before we go
ilhan omar says that the best she could
muster on that on the
the killing by the louis farrakhan
follower
of the capitol police she said well you
know it would have been worse
if uh if he had an ar-15
of course don't forget at the capitol
where there's no evidence that police
officers died as a direct result of the
the trump rioters we're the only person
the only people who died as a result
direct result that we know of the
of the riot were trump supporters most
notably ashley bobbitt who was killed by
capitol police
and you remember ilhan omar and all the
rest saying this was the worst basically
the most awful thing that's ever
happened in american history
well the best she could say about this
as well you know would have been worse
with an ar-15
well the federal government has data
that show that just isn't the case
according to 2018 data provided by the
cdc
national vital statistics
falling down killed 126 times as many
people
as rifles of any kind including the
dread assault weapons the dread ar-15
you you won't hear that in in falling
legislation
and i don't know knee control or
something stair control no you won't
hear that you will hear a lot about gun
control in the coming
days and weeks and years from the left
it doesn't really matter the the facts
of this the reality of this
the ultimate reality of of death
which we all should have been paying
attention to on easter sunday
that won't really matter because what
the left is after is
ginning up fear and by ginning up your
fear
and dividing you and dividing you and
dividing you
in a cult of the fear of death the
ultimate fear
they will be able to control you you're
going to let them do it i hope not
hope we're all like that canadian pastor
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
nols show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt walsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show